I mean overall I've got to say that I
strongly dislike whenever you see a
creator giving in to public outcry and
changing their artwork because of
complainers so if you want to hear what
my thoughts are on this happy deathday
controversy then stick around to the end
of this video welcome back to dead talks
the show where I don't release the
episode a day early because we don't
want to mess with the YouTube algorithm
so much my job is just me trying to
appease the mighty algorithm so that you
people can actually see my videos but
Blom house is the company who made one
of the newer franchises in horror and
it's called seven in heaven no I'm
kidding but you already saw the title so
you know that we're talking about happy
deathday to you and happy deathday to
you is getting a new release date thanks
to a tweet so that reads my daughter and
sixteen others were killed on February
14th Universal Studios is releasing a
movie called happy death day to you I
get the pun on Valentine's Day for me it
will always be the day that my daughter
was murdered please reconsider this he
is of course referring to the Florida
school incident that happened last year
Universal responded by issuing the
following statement when Universal
Pictures became aware last week that the
one-year anniversary of the tragic
events in parkland Florida fell on the
happy deathday to you release dates the
studio spoke with its victim advocates
and immediately began the process of
changing the release date of the film so
they moved it up to February 13th so
what do I think about this well if you
came here to see me rip them a new one
for caving into societal pressure I
guess you're gonna be disappointed
because I mean this move seems more or
less fine to me but I do have some
thoughts about it the title is literally
happy death day
and this day happens to be the one-year
anniversary it sounds a weird singing
anniversary because usually anniversary
is like you're celebrating something but
it is the one-year mark of one of the
most prolific American tragedies of 2018
so just from the title alone I think
it's kind of understandable just because
it seems to be such a specific reference
and moving up the release date doesn't
really hurt anything
if you were planning on seeing it on the
14th you still can if you're a huge
happy deathday fan and you already
pre-ordered for the 14th I'm sure you
can still get your ticket changed if you
want to it's not like they changed the
contents of the movie or worse cancel
I mean the artistic intention isn't
changed by moving up the release date
now I know that there are some films
that actually do have creativity put
into the release date but it's not like
they're moving a Star Wars movie off of
May the 4th or altering don't hug me I'm
scared from a June 19th release date I
mean it's February 14th it's clearly
just to try to cash in on people go into
the movies for Valentine's moving the
release date by one day seems like a win
for everyone
it appeases those affected by the
shooting it doesn't really affect the
studio and it even kind of makes them
look like the good guy and fans can see
it a day early or still see it on the
same day if they want to but there are
people voicing their voices about this
sorry this is ridiculous tragedies
happen every day but I feel like this is
such a specific example because of the
title I mean if people were to go out
and start complaining about other horror
movies and other release dates because
ex movie has blood and why tragedy has
blood then I would say we've crossed the
line at that point but for happy
deathday I'd say it's a good idea to
move it now they also announced that
they won't be marketing the movie in
that area of Florida which is fine and
they won't be screening it there either
which kind of reminds me of how Sony
didn't show Slenderman in parts of
Minnesota because of the Slender Man
stabbing that happened over there
cancelling the screening seems a little
bit like maybe unfair to the fans who
just innocently wanted to see the movie
and now they have to travel to see it I
mean I was thinking they could just let
the movie play and just pull the
marketing and it's not like anyone would
be forced to buy tickets but then I
think about the classmates going to the
movies and just seeing that on the
marquee and it's not as if people are
gonna see a happy deathday up on the
marquee and just burst into tears I mean
it has been a full year but I do
understand how it's kind of a class act
for Universal to pull the film in that
area and it won't be impossible for the
people who really want to see it to make
the drive so I don't really think it
adds a big of a deal as some of the
people who I understand are probably the
vocal minority are making it out to be
be sure to let me know your thoughts on
this in the comments like I said
hopefully this is just a one-time thing
because it's so specific and it's not
gonna snowball into a situation where
all horror movies are banned on the day
of every shooting because the way things
are going there
aren't gonna be a whole lot of days
laughs I'll see you in the next one
[Music]